je trouve qu'on accède beaucoup trop
facilement ses deux ports dont il suffit
de savoir lire et de savoirs cliquer sur
une souris pour pouvoir accéder sur des
milliers et des milliers et des milliers
de contenus j'ai encore des messages de
mineurs j'ai également reçu des photos
d'un mineur des photos intimes d'un
mineur donc voilà c'est là la seule
question que je me pose c'est où sont
les parents non ce n'est pas les enfants
de 12 ans ça va bien en dessous et des
gamins de 6 ans de 7 ans qui tombe sur
des images pour nous c'est du clic du
ctic du clic c'est pas à nous comme à
notre époque on regardait la vhs de nos
parents on la mettait dans le
magnétoscope et ç'a duré deux minutes
là ça dure des heures et des heures et
des heures jusqu'à maintenant rien n'a
été mis en place et on sait les dégâts
que ça peut avoir sur des adolescents et
des enfants quand quand il n'y a aucun
accompagnement aucune pédagogie qui est
absolument rien pour le moment où je
pense on est prêt à regarder du porno
déjà faut savoir qui est loi c'est
interdit aux moins de 18 ans mais le
moment on est prêt à regarder du porno
c'est le moment on arrive à avoir du
recul sur ce convoi
est pas être dans la reproduction de ce
qu'on a vu avec sa petite amie ou son
petit ami il faut être falloir une
maturité pour regarder ce genre de
choses pour moi l'état doit prendre ses
responsabilités
l'éducation nationale ainsi que les
parents donc il faut qu'ils la pédagogie
expliquer pourquoi c'est interdit
expliqué que ce sont des images créées
par des adultes pour des adultes et
certainement pas pour des enfants moi
j'ai vu telle ou telle pratique
ça m'a heurté mais il faut en parler
parce que le problème c'est que quand on
voit des images comme ça et qu'on est
adolescent on n'en parle pas on stocke
là dedans mais on n'en parle pas et
moment ça commence à devenir compliqué
donc il faut décrypter ces images là et
ça nous tous d'avoir ce rôle là dans des
temps de
repas la famille on peut essayer de
parler de ces choses là qu'est ce que tu
as vu sur les réseaux sociaux est ce que
toi tu penses que c'est normal ou je
sais pas mais ouvrir le dialogue c'est
ultra important pourquoi ne pas se
rapprocher de professionnels qui
travaillent dans cette industrie là
de parler avec eux de
de se rapprocher d'eux pour peut-être
mettre des choses en place je sais pas
des conférences où ce système de
questions réponses anonymes ou voilà mes
deux de parler de ça et de ne pas mettre
tout ça sur le tapis parce que c'est de
plus en plus urgent quand je reçois des
messages encore deux mineurs dans ma
boîte réception instagram voulant avoir
des rapports sexuels avec moi je me dis
que le problème n'a toujours pas changé
et n'a pas il ya toujours pas eu de
solution donc il ya un moment faudrait
peut-être se bouger parce que tout
interdire c'est bien mais si derrière il
n'y a pas un travail de fond ça sert un
peu à rien quoi il faut quand même
prendre bien conscience que non les
enfants les gamins c'est pas des petit
ange ils vont pas forcément regarder que
bully ou je ne sais quelle autre vidéo
d'humoristes marrant sur youtube il ya
énormément de choses ne serait ce que
par exemple sur tik tok ou cd vidéos qui
sont hyper sexualisée moi quand je vois
des par exemple des gamines de 9 à 8 en
dix ans qui se met en scène sur ces
réseaux sociaux là qu'ils peuvent
ensuite tombé sur twitter il ya des
images pornos mais réseaux sociaux
twitter par exemple je m'en sers pour
faire la promotion de mon boulot pour
autant je suis une adulte je sais que
ces images peuvent être vus par des
mineurs donc je pense que nous déjà en
tant que travailleurs du sexe on doit on
se doit de prendre nos responsabilités
on n'est pas obligé de publier des des
scènes où des images trash sur les
réseaux sociaux ça ne nous empêchera pas
de faire notre pub malheureusement
beaucoup ne pensent pas comme moi ou
comme certains de mes collègues
donc nous déjà on doit prendre nos
responsabilités les réseaux sociaux
doivent un minimum quand même modérée
parce que moi quand je vois du
scatophile sur twitter je suis désolé
c'est pas normal jusqu'à très récemment
je suis tombé sur une vidéo d'une maman
tu faisais du détournement de mineur
avec sa propre fille donc qui mettait en
scène un peu sa fille dans des
discussions à un peu très sexy pour
appâter des clients donc voilà donc
enfin c'est de pire en pire donc tout le
monde doit prendre ses responsabilités
les réseaux sociaux les travailleurs du
sexe les bars en l'état l'éducation
nationale